which the Republican National Committee
confirms president Trump will go to
Jacksonville Florida to accept the
party's nomination for re-election that
means skipping the GOP convention in
Charlotte when North Carolina's
coronavirus restrictions will limit the
size of the crowd Nikole Killion is in
Bridgewater New Jersey near the Golf
Club where the president is spending the
weekend Nicole he's being criticized
over next Friday's rally explain why
we're glad some African American
lawmakers object to holding this rally
on Juneteenth which is an annual
celebration to commemorate the end of
slavery they also object to the location
in Tulsa Oklahoma where hundreds of
blacks were massacred by white mobs
nearly a century ago in response to the
backlash the Trump campaign says the
president has quote built a record of
success for black Americans at this as
he defends one of his most controversial
tweets more than eight minutes of horror
in his first interview since George
Floyd's death
president Trump condemned the incidents
but he stood by law enforcement and
defended his now controversial tweet in
which he threatened the use of the
military in Minnesota and said when the
looting starts the shooting starts it
means two things
very different things what is if there's
looting there's probably going to be
shooting and that's not as a threat
that's really just effect because that's
what happens and the other is if there's
looting there's going to be shooting and
it's also used as a threat it's used
both ways in Dallas at a roundtable on
race and policing the president said
he's finalizing an executive order
related to the use of force and doubled
down on dominating the streets we're
doing it with compassion if you think
about it we're dominating the street
with compassion because we're saving
lives and we're saving businesses the
White House did not invite the county's
top three law enforcement officials
including Dallas County Sheriff Marion
Brown when you initiate a conversation
and you purport that conversation to be
about racism and policing in America and
you fail to include
the top three law enforcement officials
in an area where you are speaking I
think that that says a lot and that
causes one to raise the brow this all on
the heels of a stunning apology from the
chairman of the Joint Chiefs of Staff
mark Milley who said he regretted taking
part in president Trump's photo-op in
front of st. John's Church last week as
a commissioned uniformed officer it was
a mistake but I've learned from so upset
about the day's events
when peaceful protesters were forcibly
cleared from Lafayette Square that he
even considered resigning it could not
have been there my presence in that
moment and in that environment created a
perception of the military involved in
domestic politics
late last night a defense secretary Mark
espera announced a review of the
National Guard's response to the recent
a civil unrest he said it will address a
range of issues including training and
deployment tomorrow the president will
speak at the graduation for the US
Military Academy at West Point Gale
Nicole